alright I'd like to thank the organizers
for inviting me I've been enjoying this
workshop quite a bit I'm going to tell
you today about some work that I've done
in collaboration with some colleagues at
the University of Washington who I'll
introduce to you in a bit a lot of this
work came out of my participation in the
encode consortium which I've been
involved in sort of peripheral II since
its inception back in two thousand three
and one of the frequent pieces of
feedback that we get from the from the
scientific community is that they're not
happy with our selection of which
particular cell types we chose to do the
analysis on this is you know an
understandable frustration the the
process of deciding which which kinds of
assays to do in which cell types was
necessarily a little bit of a wild west
in the beginning of encode many of these
technologies didn't even exist the
beginning of encode everything was chip
chip and it was became clear eventually
that maybe we should be doing chip seek
instead for example and a lot of the
decisions were made based on practical
considerations like can we get cells in
enough quantity to distribute them to
lots of different labs and so on but as
we grow the the amount of data in that
encode has produced it becomes clear
that there's we would like a more
systematic way to make these kinds of
decisions so this is an annotation sort
of a schematic that shows the available
data in in the encode data matrix at
this point on this axis you have cell
types these can be you know you can
think of them as sort of tissues and so
on a lot of them are immortalized cell
lines but there are also primary tissues
as well and then along this axis there
are assay types some things like
chromatin accessibility assays like DNA
is one of course all the kinds of
histone modification assays that we
talked about for chip seek and then many
many transcription factor chip seek
essays as well and the black dots up
here are all of the ones that exist and
all of the white is stuff that hasn't
been done yet so
of I think yesterday I checked and there
were 3373 data sets that had been done
in human and you can see that this makes
a very small proportion of the matrix of
possible experiments that one could do
across all of these cell types and of
course the axes here go on right there's
tons and tons of additional types of
cells and perturbations and experimental
conditions and so on that you could
imagine a saying and of course many
other transcription factors for example
that have that have antibodies that we
haven't done any experiments on and so
and also I wanted to make the point that
as this data has evolved one of the
things that encode has been trying to do
is develop standards for analyzing this
data I think Eric pointed out rightly
that initially like in phase 2 of encode
there really wasn't much in the way of
standardization because it you know the
technologies were quite new at this
point all of these data are actually
available from the encode project org
website they've all been uniformly
processed by the data Coordination
Center so that that problem at least has
been addressed okay so the question that
we we're faced moving forward and this
is a question not just for encode but
for scientists in lots of different
situations is if we want to decide on
doing some new experiments we presumably
have a limited amount of cash and we
want to get the most bang for the buck
right so the question is what should if
the particular question that I want to
try to address is let's say that we're
disappointed that our cell type wasn't
studied at all and we're going to do a
small number of assays to try to get an
idea of what's going on in that cell
type and we would like to choose the
ones that are going to be sort of
complementary to each other so we'll
think of it it's like a panel of assays
with some costs associated with it and
we want to choose that panel so that
it's the most informative for the
purposes of this talk I'm going to
assume that all the assays are equal
cost it would be straightforward to
generalize to putting in the cost as a
sort of a weighting factor so you can
think of this as a general a specific
example of a more general class of
problems where you have some large
election of data and you want to choose
a subset of that data that try that
tries to retain the statistical
properties of the full data set so it's
a sort of a representative subset
selection you can think of this large
collection of blue dots and the red dots
might be the representatives that are
selected to represent it so this problem
the one I just described falls into this
setting but you could also imagine for
example if we wanted to train some
expensive machine learning method on the
encode data maybe you don't want to
train on all three thousand assays
because it's a gargantuan amount of data
you'd like to choose a subset that is
representative of the feller set for
we're training a computationally
expensive model or maybe even just to
try to make sense out of the data you'd
rather not visually look at all of the
data so you want a subset subset of
existing data there's also a similar
problem than I talk about later in the
talk where that comes up a lot in
protein bioinformatics where you have a
set of protein sequences and you'd like
to choose a representative subset say
for example for building homology models
and these all are examples of this
general problem okay so the the
structure of the talk is first I'm going
to tell you about an optimization
framework for this representative set
selection problem and then talk first
about choosing panels of genomics assays
and then a little bit about the protein
set selection as well and I should say
that this is joint work with my longtime
collaborator to Jeff films in electrical
engineering a graduate student in my lab
max Leigh Brecht and a graduate student
in Jeff's lab Kai way and yeah a lot of
the well I'll talk more later about what
the different roles are okay so let's
start out with an SI t question those of
you who who took the SI t remember these
kind of analogies right so you have two
things that are similar to each other
and then you have to choose the other
thing that's similar so continuous
optimization is to convexity as discrete
optimization is too and there are four
choices semi-definite pneus of
modularity differentiability and
perspicacity so everybody who thinks
that discrete optimization
is similar to that the relationship
between continuous optimization and
convexity is the same as discrete
optimization to semi definite pneus
raise your hand choose one all right we
got a few sub modularity okay
differentiability and a lot of people
apparently going to vote for
perspicacity the answer which got the
most votes is some modularity so this is
the sorry so I will explain to you what
sub modularity is if you're not familiar
with it sorry first pocasset e is
totally unrelated to mathematics so yeah
right so let me define what sub
modularity is and you can all google
perspicacity while I'm doing it so first
before I can define what a submodular
function is I have to just define what a
set function is a set function is a
function that takes a set usually called
a ground set here V and it assigns of
value to every possible subset of that
ground set so this function f here is
saying for if I select these guys that
are circled in red then we get some
value in this case 3.2 so this is the
set function and for the purposes of
this talk you can think of this number
as being related to the quality of the
subset okay so one immediate problem
that is a parent is that if you wanted
to try to maximize this particular value
the 3.2 how long do you think it would
take and using a naive algorithm to find
the best possible subset to them right
there's 2 to the N different possible
subsets so that's a long time typically
unless your subset is very small okay so
a submodular function is one that allows
us to optimize this more efficiently
than 2 to the N and to define sub
modularity it's the the basic idea is
it's the law of diminishing returns so
in this example you have a set a that's
been you
with a singleton set that has this one
example in it and then you you look at
the difference in sort of the quality or
the function value between bat set and
the initial set a and this term you can
think of as the gain that you get from
adding this one additional guy to the
set a right and here is the gain of
adding this guide to a larger set a
union B and so the law of diminishing
returns just says that this gain when
you're adding to a smaller set is larger
than the game that you get when the when
the set that you're adding to is large
okay so as you have more things new
stuff becomes less valuable to you this
you can think of if you can't keep that
straight in your head you can think of
it in terms of mcdonald's happy meals so
imagine that you're at McDonald's and
you want to get us some fries if you
just have a burger oh sorry you want to
get a drink and if you just have a
burger the cost of adding a drink is
larger than if you buy fries because the
fries make the additive cost of the
drink less so happy meal pricing at
McDonald's is an example of sub
modularity or diminishing return yes
increasing weight yeah and increasing
weight as you go okay so a nice feature
of this this general class of functions
is that you can define a relatively
simple greedy algorithm where you
essentially take an empty set and then
consider each possible member of your
ground set to add to the empty set and
choose the one that gives the most boost
to your the quality of the set that
you've got so far and this interestingly
is guaranteed to produce a solution
that's within a constant factor of the
best possible solution if you did the
full exponential enumeration of all
possible subsets so the factor is within
1 minus 1 over e or a factor of 0 point
6 3 interestingly it's it's actually the
case that this is the best you could
possibly do unless p is equal to NP
which is generally considered not to be
likely and and then finally it's also
the case that you there are some fast
versions of this algorithm that in a
practical sense run at about K log n so
it's quite quick to be able to do this
for large data sets so this kind of
thing is sort of the key result that
drives a lot of this work and in fact
the part of the reason this we got
started on this project was that my
collaborator Jeff films has been
applying sub modularity very
successfully in a variety of machine
learning applications so sub-module
optimization has been used in many
fields and economics and circuit design
and and there's been whole of a special
issue of discrete optimization journals
devoted to it but hadn't really been
used much in machine learning until the
past maybe eight years or so and it's
shown a lot of success in summarizing
things like large corpora of images you
want to find a representative set of
images or even natural language
processing you take a text choose a
subset of sentences that capture the
sort of the gestalt of the text so Jeff
sort of had this hammer and we were
looking for a nail and then encode at
this problem and they fit you know very
nicely together okay so I'm going to
show you how yeah question this is true
the limit of large n or this is a
correct statement for a good question in
the limit ah
yeah it's got to be in the limit of
large and right wait I think it's so far
every instance wonderful okay not find
out anyway that's like a book but the
number that you're optimizing write the
value that you get and the value of the
best possible are have a difference that
is no larger than this ratio yeah okay
okay so are you okay that you're
choosing is a representative subset
according to some submodular function
and you say that the quality the score
of this representative subset is within
a factor of point 6 3 m-f is the square
of the old air and then I don't
understand why it's 10 v well so there's
different f's I mean it's for any given
F right so as long as f is sub modular
then this will be true okay oh and I
should also mention it intuitively I
didn't say this earlier but you can
think of sub modularity is kind of a
representation of information in the set
so entropy is an example a canonical
example of a submodular function right
so modular is much more broad but
entropy is one common function that is
so modular okay so let's talk about the
sub this particular problem so we're
trying to decide what panel of genomics
assays should we perform on a new cell
types we imagine I've drawn this now as
sort of a tensor now you've got genomic
position going back this way here's all
the experiments that we've done we're
getting some new cell type and what
we're going to do is first compute a
matrix of a say similarities and then
give some budget so maybe in this case
the budget is we can afford to do three
assays have a selection procedure and
then get out our panel okay so for the
purposes of these results we've focused
just on using correlation as our measure
of similarity this is definitely an area
where you could imagine having other
similarity measures we didn't vary that
particular thing partly because there
was plenty of examples in the literature
of people using correlation in this way
like what Martin did a couple days ago
he showed a heat map very simple
allure to this where you were looking at
correlations there could be lots of
interesting directions to go varying how
those similarities are computed but for
now we just focused on saying two assays
are similar in the core the average
correlation of cell types where they
both been performed okay now the
challenge often in doing this kind of
optimization is deciding on your sub
modular optimization function right so
we actually tried a variety of functions
in this context in the second part of
the doc I'll tell you more about
different kinds of functions but for now
I'm just going to focus on the one that
we decided upon that worked well and
it's called Facility Location this is a
well-studied function the canonical
example that people use is you imagine
that you are Nike and you have a number
of stores in and around Paris and you
want to choose the location of your next
Nike facility how do you do that well
one way one heuristic you could imagine
is saying if I sort of average over all
the places where people live in and
around Paris you'd like everyone to live
pretty close to one nike store so you
you sort of think of it as sum over all
the people there the distance from that
person to the nearest nike facility and
that just is the facility location
function so you're taking in this case
the sum of similarities to the most
similar representative this is meant to
represent the distances from this guy to
the nike store and so on so you're
adding up all of the the lengths of
those red lines or the similarities and
that becomes the facility location
function so those are the two things
that we use to do this calculation we
take these correlations we use those as
our similarity function and then we can
compute for any given set of assays the
total similarity among them among all
the other assays in the ground set to
the assays in our panel okay so the
question is how do we know if it worked
you can start by saying so we did this
for example for a bunch of histone
modification assays these are just a
browser shot representation of different
histone modifications so this is
histone 3 lysine 27 is sat elation and
all these different codes stand for
different modifications and sort of you
can see the I've marked the ones in
black that are the first five that were
selected by the sub modular the greedy
algorithm and you know you can sort of
wave your hands and say things like oh
they do show sort of qualitatively
different characteristics some have
broader shapes and summer are more
punctate but just visually obviously is
not going to be very easy to say whether
this is a good panel in any absolute
sense so one thing that we did was go
and look at how a panel of experts had
what what a panel of experts had decided
so here is the choice order for our sub
modular optimization procedure if we
look at what the people in roadmap
decided to choose they actually chose
these 5 so 5 out of the first six that
were selected by this procedure so
that's at least encouraging I also not
proof but it seems like there's least
some agreement there before I go into
the the systematic measurement of how
good this is I think it's worthwhile to
think a little bit about what how we
make sense out of this ranking so this
is that same list in rank order and now
i'm showing next to each one three
different numbers one of them is just
the sub modular score of this particular
assay by itself if you selected it first
with no others that's this modular value
here right this is the conditional game
which is if we add this to the previous
one how much additional value do we get
and then this is just the running total
here right so one thing that's unusual
about this list well actually maybe I
can ask you what's what's one thing that
anyone who's familiar intimate with
these histone mods that makes you
unhappy about this list anyone who
particularly yeah
that wasn't what it was supposed to be
that might also what's wrong with the k4
motto maybe between this the mono the
tribe there's nothing I say interesting
ok that's the one that I was expecting
the one about enhancers but that might
also i'll have to look i haven't looked
into that question particularly i've
seen that publishing right maybe waiting
to the fact that correlations might not
be because he did you find the enhancer
because often when you have died or tri
methyl you also have some monomethyl
mm-hmm monomethyl you don't have tri
methyl there is it for with you right so
there's there's this pants right and
your score may sort of not be so
sensitive to those kind of these
correlations yes that's right so in
particular a lot of people like to use
this very last one here as a very strong
mark for enhancers and if you
interestingly it's the only one with a
conditional gain of zero so at least in
this setting it's saying if you've got
these ten there's no reason to even
bother doing the eleventh it doesn't
give you any more it doesn't get you
closer to anyone in paris right but the
nice thing is that we can we can adapt
this protocol to say let's imagine that
somebody has already done h3k27 AC or
they really are definitely want to do HD
k-27 AC and now let's just do the
optimization from from there on so we
say this one is fixed and now what
should we do next given that we've got
we've already done that one and so you
start seeing that on the one hand the
conditional gain from this is smaller
than quite a variety several of the
other are sorry not the conditioner the
modular value of this one is smaller
than several of the other assays so
that's why it wasn't selected first but
also as you go down this list you're
consistently a little bit lower in the
total quality of the panel than you are
if you hadn't started with h3k27 AC so
at least in that in according to this
metric if the corresponding values here
it seems like putting this guy up at the
top
the list is not necessarily a good idea
yes what sure well it's a it's a
confusing analogy because i was using
distance but we're using similarity but
it's you know imagine like one over the
correlation or something like that to
fit it into the nike analogy but its
correlation that's right across the
genome difference because all these
reaching centric so like the left panel
is so cheap a small genomic real space
right right so one of the things when i
gave this talk few weeks ago and we're
computing these correlations is
computationally kind of slow so we
haven't finished it yet chi said it was
not quite done when i emailed in with
two nights ago but one of the things
that we'd like to do is try this again
with correlations that are computed on a
subset of the genome that is sort of
biologically more relevant to what we're
interested in so that could be what
we're doing right now is DHS's but you
could imagine doing it on you know genic
regions or something like that yeah does
it make sense to include in the
correlations um like a mother functional
output of the system so for example gene
expression because for example h3k27 a
settled maybe is correlated with
everything this one percent promoters
mm-hmm but if what it tells us the
difference in activity so the question
is could you imagine incorporating
something like gene expression I think
you would have to build that as far as I
can see into the similarity measure
somehow you know you could imagine to
some kind of weighted correlation I
guess I'm not sure it's not immediately
obviously you could fit that into the
submodular function per se but if you if
you could find a way to put it into the
similarity perhaps okay so oh yeah
you already know the values of the
correlation but you are asking about the
new essay for which you have no
information right so the queer using the
so in this setting we're assuming that
the essay has been done in some other
cell type and we're using the
correlations in other cell types in
which it's been done but if you have
never done the essay before then there's
no way you could know how much
information it will give you yeah export
nation might not right remember that so
the question is the correlation that
we're computing is an average over all
the cell types in which the two assays
have been done and if one essay has been
done many times it's a much larger
average so presumably a smaller variance
in whatever it's estimating you're right
that could be an issue I don't see it it
doesn't seem like you want to ignore
when there are lots of assays to compute
the correlation from but I don't I don't
have any good solution for that problem
it is something that has come up before
I don't let me just go on and we can
have more questions later I'll just say
briefly that we also can do this for
example for example for transcription
factors what are we all ready okay well
we might not do the second half but
that's okay the second half was you know
ok so the we also do this for
transcription factors you can see for
example most of the transcription
factors that we do in encode our
standard you know transcription factors
that bind it promoters which is what
these first three are here but then you
also have for example things involved in
crumpton confirmation and then one of
the one of them that's RNA polymerase
initiation complex and also these guys
are quite different from each other but
all of this begs the question how do we
how can we sort of objectively evaluate
whether this is a good summary this was
something that we had to wrestle with
quite a bit in this in this project and
what we ended up doing was saying well
let's think about how one might use one
of these represent
panels and then try to evaluate it in
that context so for example you might
try to use a panel to impute data for
the the data that's not in your
representative set you might try to use
it to identify functional elements
promoters and enhancers and so on and
you might also try to use it for semi
automated genome annotation like
chromhmm or segway these kind of things
so we designed a sort of general cross
sort of train test cross validation
scheme where we would take all of the
available data we look at an evaluating
cell type and all of the the assays that
are available in that cell type and we
would split them up we partition them
into what we call a source set at a
target set we do the assay panel
selection on the source set and then we
do an evaluation to compare the selected
panel to the held out target set and get
some quality measure so for each of
those three scenarios we replace this
box with a different operation so in the
first scenario that evaluation box we're
splitting the genome into a train and
test set we train a regression model in
this case the support vector regresar do
a prediction and just see how well
what's the r-squared between those two
in the functional element prediction
it's very similar except now we're
taking an annotation in this case it's
things like chip seek peaks for known
factors and just looking at the area
under the precision recall curve and
then for semi automated genome
annotation we take the we partition the
genome and assign it labels and then ask
how much variance does this annotation
explained in the held out data and the
first thing we did was just look and see
to what extent the facility location
function agrees with these various
external evaluation metrics so each of
these vertical axes are one of those
three things this is the r-squared there
yendor the precision recall curve and
the variance explained and all the blue
dots here are just randomly selected
subsets we also included sort of here is
just sort of one heuristic for choosing
a subset which is what is the panel of
assays that it was most frequently
performed across all the cell types
then here's what was selected by the sub
modular procedure if we do this more
systematically this is just many
different random selections and here's
the sub modular optimization again I put
the most frequently performed a say in
here and now we're doing it for
different panel sizes and so you can see
that in in all of these situations the
the selection does a good job of
optimizing this thing we that was just
for one cell type in the in the
manuscript there we show it on a variety
of different cell types and then we also
showed that you could generalize this to
the setting where we're choosing among
existing assays as opposed to an
entirely new cell type we want to choose
things from within a set of existing
assays and I'm just going to I'll tell
you that that worked well as well
because I know that much time and then
what I like a minute or two minutes let
me just briefly say then this is in a
actually I think this is on our yeah
this is on bio archive I'm not gonna
have time to go through the details but
one of the things that we struggled with
in that first half was how do you
objectively evaluate how this works and
one of my motivations for showing you
the protein summarization task was that
in that setting we really do have an
orthogonal gold standard which is the
protein structure so this version of the
problem is just something that people
have been doing since the mid-90s you
want to find a non redundant set of
proteins that you're going to use for
building a model of one kind or another
or doing any kind of analysis these you
know these are the methods that people
use CD hit I think is the most popular
there's about four thousand citations in
google scholar but i think that way
under under counts how often these kind
of methods are used because they're just
a part of many bioinformatics pipelines
and so in this second half which you're
not going to here we go through and
compared to we do summarization zhan the
scop gold standard the scalp set of
sequences and then ask how well our
summary covers all of the different
superfamilies in scoff according to the
structure and in that case we're able to
show according to this independent gold
standard that we do much better than
then this the existing published methods
and maybe I'll stop there and take more
questions thank you when you defined
your problem it's a very general
optimization problem and a hammer and a
very general heaven the function the
facility selection function also it's
not driven by any biological motivation
the reason why you would want to look at
the data only came in at the end in the
application the validation set let's
maybe how encode works but if I want to
explore my particular selter might have
a biological idea from the bodega
beginning so can you think of ways to
change your whatever I was called this
this this F function you to be more
biological yeah so actually this is
something that I had on my notes on one
of the slides and forgot to say so thank
you for the question the thing that
we're doing right now there are
established methods for learning the
submodular function so you can
parameterize a space not all possible
sub modular functions but a subset of
sub modular functions that are
parametrized and then you can learn the
function itself and that's what we're
going to do we're focusing on doing it
in the protein sequence case because
then we really have this orthogonal gold
standard but that's clearly where a lot
of the value lies and I should have
pointed that out earlier other questions
okay
okay oh yeah
yeah so that I've thought of we've
thought of doing this I was not thinking
of evolutionary but i was thinking in
human populations if you wanted to you
know imagine trying to test some kind of
clinical treatment and you've got a
population of 10,000 people but you can
only afford to test it in a thousand
which individuals should you should you
choose you could look at their genetic
diversity and try to choose a panel in
that way and yes this would directly
apply to that choosing what experiments
to do I creatively adaptive yes
certainly so if you so remember I showed
how you could put in h3k27 and assume
you'd done that one right if you wanted
to you could run your greedy algorithm
find out who's next then put it in and
recompute your correlations based on
that right and then do the next one so
that you could make it adaptive in that
sense am I really remembering that sub
modular optimization can actually know
in polynomial time assuming for any
subset you know its value which seems to
be the same assumption sitting for any
subset you I'm not sure what you mean
the greedy algorithm abduction need to
know for a particular subset what its
value is great okay and
a relative to that so you have to be
able to evaluate that's what the
submodular function computes right so
you have to be able to compute the sub
knowledge of function on any given
subset but then there's a polynomial
time algorithm that actually looked well
there's an alga that only looks at a
polynomial number of subsets in order to
find the optimal but not the true
optimal just within just within the one
minus one over rebound that's what I'm
asking I don't believe that's right but
minimizing a submodular function can be
done and fall on it and maxima is that
what you think you think of minimizing
that could be it they're out there
that's true request all right thank you